ultima thule ist ein himmelskörper im
äußeren sonnensystem und sein name hat
einige kontroversen ausgelöst weil ihnen
viele menschen mit der nazizeit
verknüpfen die nasa sich so sehr unter
druck dass sie nun maßnahmen ergriffen
hat tricks um science-fiction hier
gibt's täglich spannende science videos
aber nicht den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen eigentlich
ist ultima thule nicht besonders
skandalös aber ungewöhnlich das objekt
befindet sich hinter pluto in den
äußeren bereichen des sonnensystems und
wurde anfang 2009 10 von der raumsonde
new horizons genauer unter die lupe
genommen man fand heraus dass der
himmelskörper aus zwei aneinander kleben
den asteroiden besteht und wegen dieser
charakteristischen form gab man ihm den
spitznamen schneemann der offizielle
name ultima thule stammt eigentlich aus
der griechischen mythologie der
abenteurer peters behauptete im vierten
jahrhundert vor christus dass es ganz
weit im norden eine geheimnis von der
insel namens schule gäbe zwar haben sich
niemals beweise für eine insel namens
tote gefunden doch der mythos hielt sich
noch weit bis ins mittelalter es
existieren sogar karten aus dem 16
jahrhundert auf denen die insel
verzeichnet ist obwohl sie ja scheinbar
gar nicht existiert doch jetzt kommt der
problematische tat anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts vereinnahmten
nationalsozialistische gruppen den
begriff für sich so gründete sich im
jahr 1918 beispielsweise die thule
gesellschaft eine rechtsextreme
organisation die eine mythische
abstammung der germanen auf der insel
thule proklamierte eben jene verwendung
des begriffs schule flog der nasa jetzt
um die ohren man wählte den namen weil
man die ferne insel thule ganz passend
für einen verlassenen außenposten im
hinteren sonnensystem jedoch scheinbar
rechnet die nasa nicht mit so viel
kritik an dem namen weil er eben auch in
rechtsextremen kreisen verwendet wird
noch im januar sagte der missionschef
der nasa einen stern folgendes nur weil
einige böse menschen diesen begriff 1
morton werden wir nicht zulassen dass
sie ihn allein für sich beanspruchen
doch scheinbar wurde die kritik nun zu
heftig die nasa entschied sich dafür
den himmelskörper umzubenennen der neue
name a roko stammt aus der sprache des
indianerstammes der bau hat an und
bedeutet himmel nazi kontroverse ultima
thule in diesem video gibt es noch mehr
hintergrundinfos also anklicken
anschauen und auf jeden fall asto comics
tv abonnieren
mega cola kanal bis dann bleibt dran